most people who are familiar with paying
for things probably know what an invoice
looks like but you may also be aware of
how challenging deciphering your cloud
invoice can be potentially with
thousands of lines of cryptic acronyms
and texts on this episode of beyond your
bill we'll walk you through how to
explore your cost using Google cloud
billing reports
[Music]
our last videos covered how resources in
your GCP account can be organized and
how to manage permissions with a billing
account in this video we'll look at how
you can explore the costs associated
with a billing account by viewing
billing reports in the Google Cloud
console we'll focus on answering some
common questions like how much am i
spending what are my cost trends and
what are my cost drivers I'll use a
sample billing account for this video
but you can go to the cloud console and
use the left hand navigation to click on
billing and then reports to view billing
reports for your own billing accounts
and projects the report defaults to the
current calendar month and shows you a
lot of information right off the bat in
the top left you can see the cost to
date for the current month and how that
compares to the cost for the same time
period in the previous month in the top
right you can see the forecasted cost
for the current month and how that
compares to the cost from the previous
month right in the middle there's a
chart that shows cost group by project
each color shows a different project and
you can hover over the chart to see more
specific details there's also a dotted
cost trend line that forecasts what your
spending might look like in the future
based on historical trends under the
chart you'll see a list of projects in a
table view in addition there are filters
on the right side to drill down and
further analyze your costs you can
customize the time range you're
currently viewing
so you could explore previous months the
past quarter or any other window of time
in addition you can toggle the invoice
month to line up the report directly to
your invoice when looking at your cost
by invoice you'll be able to filter out
specific charges such as taxes this is
the best way to get an exact visual
representation of the invoices sent to
your company and to explore the costs
associated with each project or service
you can also choose from other filters
to see how your costs are trending as
you change the time range the cost and
comparative costs above the graph will
update based on your view you're also
able to filter cost by location
selecting of geography region or multi
region area this is especially handy to
see a cost breakdown by region such as
comparing your costs between the
Americas and amia click a location to
include it in your filtered view and
deselect all the locations to go back to
the default view there's also the
ability to selectively filter out
credits which can be made up of
different discounts based on your usage
such as sustained
discounts and committed use discounts
for example if you have a lot of
consistent compute engine usage you may
see a big impact from sustained use
discounts sometimes you need to drill in
to see what's driving a spike in your
cost in this particular billing account
we can see that some pretty big spikes
have occurred recently by hovering over
the chart it looks like one specific
project is responsible the next step is
to drill in further to understand what
caused it we'll filter to just the
specific project responsible and then
group by product to see more information
having a consistent and clear naming
convention comes in handy here so that
you can track down the right information
about the project usage for our example
it looks like a rise in bigquery usage
is responsible for this bike but we can
see even more detail if we filter by SKU
this reveals that bigquery analysis is
what's causing the increase which is the
SKU for running queries and bigquery
with the GCB project and specific cause
outlined it should be a lot easier to
narrow down what action or application
is driving the cost so the billing
reports let you see your costs and drill
down into specific areas to monitor and
investigate unexpected changes in cost
if you're just looking for a high-level
summary of your costs try the cost
breakdown report which you can also
access from the left-hand menu from a
billing account this report lets you see
how discounts and taxes combined with
your usage costs to arrive at your final
invoice amount every month using these
different reports can show you a clearer
picture of your costs for different
scenarios using the billing reports
available to you directly within the
console you can see what you're
currently spending visualize the amount
your forecasted to spend and understand
your cost drivers in the next video
we'll look at how to export your billing
data for further analysis and create
custom dashboards
[Music]